han sido incapaces de encontrar prueba
alguna en mi contra porque no hay nada
que encontrar
absolutamente nada
yo Admito errores en mi gestión pero soy
un demócrata y he procurado que las
soluciones sean siempre
constitucionales y legales
me he esforzado para que el diálogo
político sea la herramienta que
garantice gobernabilidad y estabilidad
que permitan a cada poder del Estado
cumplir con sus atribuciones y
responsabilidades
pero el ataque a la gestión de este
gobierno no tiene límites los ministros
del interior defensa salud inclusión
social entre otros han recibido más de
1.300 pedidos de información
y han sido llamados a comparecer en más
de trescientas ocasiones en dos años de
gobierno
hay ministros que han tenido en un solo
día hasta cinco comparecencias
han activado
catorce juicios políticos para generar
inestabilidad en el gabinete y
entorpecer el trabajo del gobierno
es inaceptable que gran parte del tiempo
de los ministros y sus equipos esté
dedicado a resistir el acoso político de
la asamblea nacional en lugar de
gestionar la solución de los problemas
de las familias ecuatorianas
Esto no es fiscalización es una
constante
obstrucción que ha generado una grave
crisis política y conmoción interna que
se refleja en la casi nula confianza de
la sociedad ecuatoriana en la asamblea
nacional
para dar una salida constitucional al
Ecuador
He decidido aplicar el artículo
148 de la Constitución de la república
que me otorga la Facultad de disolver la
asamblea nacional por grave crisis
política y conmoción interna para lo
cual he firmado el decreto ejecutivo
número siete cuatro uno
además
he solicitado al consejo nacional
electoral la convocatoria
inmediata a elecciones legislativas y
presidenciales para el resto de los
respectivos periodos
Esta es una decisión democrática
no solo porque es constitucional
sino porque le devuelve al pueblo
ecuatoriano a ustedes el poder de
decidir Su futuro en las próximas
elecciones
Esta es la mejor decisión posible que
nos abre el camino a recuperar la
esperanza la tranquilidad y permitirá el
gobierno centrar todos sus esfuerzos en
atender las necesidades de la familia
ecuatorianas
a partir de hoy
sin bloqueos el gobierno nacional
expedirá una serie de decretos ley que
cumplirán con el mandato
soberanamente expresado por ustedes
he firmado el primer decreto ley de
urgencia económica para reducir
impuestos
fortalecer la economía de cuatrocientas
sesenta mil familias ecuatorianas Y qué
significará que cerca de 200 millones de
dólares regrese a sus hogares
este decreto ley será remitido a la
corte constitucional para su dictamen
el Ecuador no se detiene los servicios
públicos atenderán con normalidad
las fuerzas armadas y la Policía
Nacional
continúan garantizando seguridad con su
labor diaria de enfrentar a la
delincuencia y al terrorismo
el sector privado tiene todas las
garantías para desarrollar sus
actividades y seguir contribuyendo al
crecimiento y desarrollo del país
Este es un nuevo momento para el
optimismo
construyamos juntos un futuro mejor para
el Ecuador
por último
invocando una vez más las palabras del
presidente Jaime roldós termino este
mensaje
mi poder en la Constitución y mi corazón
en el pueblo ecuatoriano